thank you
[Music]
Montana has a new law can't wait to hear
it it's called SB 419 what do you think
it does
the big one nope nope not skateboarding
not mushrooms
uh you're gonna like it okay good
we're blind why do you think I'll like
it something to do it's self-defense you
can't pretend to be blind yeah if it's
something he's gonna like what do you
think it's about yeah that's actually
more fun game yeah based on the mind of
Nick Dunn legalizing beating up
minorities wow
criminalizing a wife beating their
husbands
send it to jail yeah send them to jail I
gotta move to Montana then brother oh my
goodness you you may want to after you
hear this so Montana's new law makes it
illegal
for um app for like phone apps to
provide service
um that accesses tick tock what oh yeah
Montana is the first state to make Tick
Tock technically illegal yeah within
state lines you just can't
each time a user accesses Tick Tock do
you guys use tick tock frequently or is
offered the ability to download it or is
offered access to it that's That's crazy
dude I mean I don't really use it that
much do you guys want to talk a lot I do
I used to I learned a lot of things yeah
I do too I learn I learned a lot of
things like history whatever I hear a
lot of things about how people learn a
lot about Tick Tock because I go on it
too sometimes but very rarely like super
rarely only when you ask me to check my
email on it and I couldn't figure that
out oh yeah sorry I couldn't hear that
I go on it sometimes I'm very skeptical
of the information that comes out on it
because it's just some guy in his
bathroom talking yeah yeah sometimes
yeah but obviously there's like The
credibility well it's also like the lens
of them giving information is for you
the consumer to be like oh that's
actually really cool I learned something
new it hit that dopamine effect of like
oh I learned something yeah and then I
follow and then sometimes learning too
much is like mental masturbation in a
lot of ways so you feel like because I
I'm dude I'm so yeah I'm so like that
guy where I'm like oh I'm reading this
ebook and I'm reading this and then
after a while you're like
yeah but like I could tell myself like
oh I read so much like look at this but
if I'm not applying the stuff that I'm
actually reading then it kind of doesn't
matter but for tick tock I feel like
people get in that habit I think it
depends on what you watch because the
stuff that I watch is yes you can learn
stuff but
um what I really like watching is just
people doing like people making things
or like whatever because that [__] you
could see the process of it so you're
learning by watching it there's no right
or wrong they're just doing it you know
what I like to watch is one guys they
clean a real dirty rug I've seen those I
get lost in them see but not on tick
tock on Instagram I learned how to clean
my carpets from Tick Tock see I learned
how to get rid of the dirt on the grout
in your on your bathroom tiles you can
learn how to like the garden you can
learn a bunch of stuff that you could
just apply right does that mean that you
uh the reasons that they wanted to make
it illegal do you agree with them I I
may or what was the reason what was the
reason because well because of uh mixed
people yeah oh that's that's like I
think when it's all said and done that's
the main reason yeah that they're using
but then do you would you rather like
because there's obviously the Facebook
leaks and stuff like ever you're being
spied on regardless of what nation but
it's okay with but it's okay when your
own country's spying on you that makes
me feel safe it makes you feel okay you
see that's that's the counter argument
to that it's like dude you're being
spied on regardless yeah but also the um
what about it what about the just purely
economic standpoint where it's like
should a foreign company have such a
large market share if the algorithm's
good because then
but what if that means your American
dollars are constantly leaving your
country yeah what kind of American are
you dude I don't know
yeah so shouldn't you download Truth
social
is that still an app
it's still a thing huh you want to get
other insults for me in my life
I don't know I have no idea what's right
I think it's it's like a YouTube but if
they're banning Tick Tock for the whole
service economic reason it's like why
are we still why aren't they Banning
Amazon for like allowing people to ship
stuff from China it's like in America's
an American company because maybe it
makes a huge difference they sell is all
from China yeah yeah through the
American Marketplace
Productions in China or okay if they
could put a rule to not let these phones
download the app why don't they make it
so that you have to download this app by
using this American app
so that they you know what I mean they
put a filter so that way everybody gets
a little piece I think the only way to
solve this is that's what they tried
yeah they did that dude went to Congress
and he spoke about hope to me being
cynical that whole thing was hey you're
making x amount uh uh millions and
hundreds of million dollars uh we want
to cut okay so come to Congress and tell
us why we should keep you that's to me
what that was that's that's what I was
saying like it's it really is even
though you hear all these other
different reasons about how it's uh a
detriment to American society how it's a
bad influence on kids all that [__] is a
vehicle to just get money it just comes
down to cash okay and power and like
domination of the market it's it's a
macro thing of like a micro level of
like you're opening a nightclub in a
certain city and then you get visited by
certain you know people yeah they're
like hey you should pay us protection
money yeah
um give us a cut like if we want a 10
off the top of whatever gonna make
that's just what the US government I
feel like is doing when they invite it's
kind of what every government has to do
like if if you've got a foreign thing
that's killing your market like if if
there's anything you can put some
tariffs on you know yeah you gotta do
something that's that's usually where it
goes I mean they would have they tried a
million things when the Japanese Auto
Market was dominating and still is now
but we don't like it right they've been
trying so what happened then like it's
well they started making they I mean
they started taxing a shitload and then
also they were doing assemblies like
here Stateside yeah forced them to have
manufacturing plans yeah yeah see but
Tick Tock in China
I think they have something similar but
it's apparently like the algorithm is
completely it's more fossil very good
like national pride right like like you
like education watching things yeah
people build things they have kids
building things like science projects so
then the kids grow up thinking oh I want
to be like that or like oh let's do this
that's all yeah that's always an
interesting thing because I was also on
board of like yeah when I look at or
when I look at what Tick Tock kind of is
about here when you see who your popular
stars are and uh the ones there it's
like there is a difference but also you
are a product of your population so
whether they may not have as much like
thoughtiness in their Tick Tock but they
don't have as much thoughts like period
yeah yeah in their cultural society in
China they're just less things like that
yeah like it might be more taboo there
there might they might be just more
underground but here it's very surface
right it's very empowered right it's not
it's not a a thing to be ashamed of as
much so I think like I don't think
they're making us see more ass I think
we're trying to to show more ass I think
it's just what do you want to see out
here because that's yeah because that's
what it is like it dictates one of the
complaints is like oh look at look at
the tick tock in China it's all like
farming and productive [__] it's like
yeah they have they just have more of
that right and that's not a mystery to
us we always we still get some of that
stuff but we want to see some butt
cheeks too yeah I mean and almost
there's a butt cheeks shaking for dollar
bills there's just more people showing
cheeks like because that's what captures
you know the audience and it's also
serving what they want uh like they
being like whoever's like kind of
writing the algorithm yeah it's like hey
I'm gonna serve them this and they're
gonna like it yeah because you know it's
like if you watch the documentary
American president with Michael Douglas
and that betting Aaron Sorkin wrote it
um there's a scene with Michael J fox
and um Martin Sheen where they're
arguing about like oh like you could
lead a horse to water and then um
Michael J fox says I'm like but when
it's sand
um you know like what do you do like
you're basically like pulling a trick on
them and I'm pulling for paraphrasing
Michael Douglas's character President
says yeah but they're stupid to know
that it's sand and they'll just keep
drinking the sand and that's what
they're served that's basically what
Tick Tock serving is like Hey we're
going to show them all this you know
whether they like it or not it's crap
but we're going to convince them some
other they like it and you know what do
we have we have like we love it
exactly that's why I'm like they're if
and they're not gonna straight up say
that like that guy when he was at that
that uh open was it when he was like
speaking in front of the house like he's
not gonna go I'm just showing you guys
what you wanted yeah yeah like he's not
gonna say that yeah yeah he's not gonna
say that but it is true it's based on
what you watch because if you took it
away yeah they took it away we would
find a way to [__] find it again and
also too in China right they got no only
fans creators over there they're not as
good as the Americans they are only fans
girls are destroying bro yeah they're
raking it in I mean it just comes down
to cultural values honestly like it's
not a it's not a secret that Asian
cultures just center around a different
form like do you think Montana's being
racist
I don't I don't think it's being racist
I I think if they want to use those
reasons as to why they don't have it
yeah I think that's fine because it
seems like it's like a masked thing like
stay American we don't want any
influence from any other I think it's
fair to say like I don't think it's a
racial thing I think I think it sucks
that like China huh it sucks hey
nowadays like we'll have you occupy the
whole country
let's say like Ireland is smart enough
to develop uh tiktok yeah Mick talk yeah
and they were and it was fun that they
were spying on us they're doing this to
crumble our society right how would we
react to it as a as a country you know
the US and I I feel like it's just an
island
a small little tiny little island before
that could be a little bit different it
would be different yeah it would 100 be
different because there's also not a lot
of like secondary and tertiary things
that are going on too like we're kind of
buying exactly yeah right like you know
Ireland is just you know they're either
Lind yeah yeah but also people a lot of
people don't realize too that Tick Tock
and the people that own it have a hard
time in China too right like they are
not getting along 100 with the Chinese
government either yeah right they are
fighting kind of both things like if you
they're just like in the middle yeah
like if you read up they they get
stepped on a shitload too by the
government because the government has a
right to just by any point stick their
hand in and go oh wait hey yeah don't do
that like they basically just took
everything yeah dude okay check them all
you guys know what he looks like right
yeah okay very handsome he's like oh you
think I was gonna say he's not the most
attractive guy in the world but
the tough guy attractive man white girls
were saying he's attractive his wife
they're both very learned graduate like
the top schools and all that they're the
power couple and I'm thinking I don't
think they're real
I feel like the the true head of tick
tock look like Jack ma
nerdy just all he did was study his
whole life but this dude is like an
international looking spy yeah and his
wife is like you know tall I think like
Stanford Harvard and all that stuff I
don't think they're they're real because
just to show a good front I bet the real
like the founder of tick tock and the
guy's face is all scrunched yeah and it
looks blind when you wear sunglasses
it was like where's like where's like
hoodies it could be yeah I mean
ultimately the head of every Chinese
company is [__] China
it's never it's never the dude right as
is what I think it's just too like how
many like American CEOs do you know that
are like Suave and like you know against
Mark Zuckerberg the MMA champion
[Music]
developed somewhere else and then China
bought it
Tick Tock I thought it was always in
China and then they really they just
like changed hands in China no it might
be I mean I mean because bite dance is
like the main owner of it's like Ireland
to come up with it I just remembered
that it was bought by China but I don't
know if it was developed in China maybe
not yeah maybe but then if you read that
it could have been like it was developed
in China and then the Chinese government
bought it so they can make money because
like you know they don't they don't do
the whole oh we want a piece of your
company they'll just take the company I
mean it was musically and then and then
it
musically got bought but I don't know if
musically was Chinese I don't know
because then it wouldn't make sense for
China to develop an app to know that the
government is good musically musically
was Chinese but I think they also do it
for like I don't think Jack was like oh
the government's gonna leave me alone I
think he knew yeah but they probably had
a plan and he made so much money yeah so
much money and then finally the
government's like all right yo yeah yeah
they can step in at any time I mean dude
that with what's her name is it bing
bing Fang oh when she like disappeared
when she disappeared and then now she's
like oh no I was good so if stuff like
that happens it's like doesn't that make
people it doesn't discourage people from
wanting to even start I think the ones
on the fence it does but if you're like
an artist or you're a business person
and that's your true passion you're
probably like you know what no I gotta
do this to survive like my own
livelihood my own well-being they
probably still do it right but they know
that something's gonna happen once they
get to a certain level but you also but
you also don't assume you're gonna be
like the richest person in China I think
it's discouraging if you moved from here
to China if you're born it's always been
that way it's always been like hey you
don't know you know like do me a favor
I'll do you a favor right like even the
shows that I worked on they would
someone would there'd be like one
representative that's the government's
opinion yeah and they would have to stop
everything for this one dude he would be
on set on like stages that they built
like all this stuff and just go no
change the music make it a China music
like it would be doing like some Usher
[__] like no Drake China music today
everything changes that day or they go
like uh more patriotic or or they told
Hawk because Hawk's hair was like died
like Hat wear a hat wow because you have
to show that you're proud of your
genetics you can't have blonde hair on a
Chinese show if you're a guy yeah it's
like weird it's like little things like
that this is just one guy and all these
people who were [__] billionaires
around them have to [__] listen to
them that's great it's not otherwise
they lose yeah then they lose their
right to make money it's almost like
that it's like hey we're letting you be
rich yeah so you have to do what we say
because there's also ethereum so I'm at
a uh I don't know if he's Mafia but like
he's basically underworld guy in
Thailand uh he's from Malta and he told
me
my whole life my whole career I only
wanted to make five percent of what my
boss made
that dude has like a strip mall he's a
poor she's got like clubs because all he
he's all I focus on is five percent I
don't want to be greedy so that way the
people above me don't look out for me
and like are like cautious of me
so there's probably people like that in
China they know what's going on like
billionaires run in the same Circle and
they talk to each other they probably
help each other out and they go hey
don't do this it's going to cause
concern and you'll lose it they just
kind of skate between the lines just
enough to where and Jack probably was
like nah Playa I'm gonna do what I want
yeah and the government's like okay
come come meet with us for a few days
there's no history of anyone ever
winning against them and you don't hear
you don't hear Jack say anything now
yeah if you want to hear what he has to
say you gotta watch Chen Yoon